[Aplausos]
no es que un día me levanté con ganas de
hacer algo y simplemente lo hice lo que
pasa es que cada mañana me levanto
totalmente convencido de aplicar esos
pequeños esfuerzos para desarrollar mi
propósito de vida amigos el día de hoy
quiero compartir con ustedes el tema de
propósito
tenemos que trabajar por un propósito y
en ese propósito hay que dar
prácticamente todo lo que está en
nosotros el día de hoy quiero
compartirles un concepto construido por
un servidor a partir las experiencias
que he tenido el concepto que quiero
compartir con ustedes el día de hoy
tiene que ver con una palabra compuesta
que desarrolle y se llama competencia la
competencia está conformada por un
prefijo que se llama que se denomina ep
es decir sobre de o más allá de la idea
es de que la competencia tiene que
llevarnos a algo más allá del yo
competente que me encantaría compartir
con ustedes si pudiera definir el
concepto de epi competencia lo definiría
con cuatro palabras 1 método 2
constancia
3 introspección o reflexión y 4 hábito
una vez que pasa por ese proceso la epic
competencia permite ir más allá del yo
competente
eso es lo que quiero compartirles
durante mi charla y ahora voy a todos
los detalles
la realidad es de que todo lo que hice
estaba muy vinculada hace
aproximadamente 40 días estaba en una
conferencia de un biólogo que trae un
best-seller que se llama la creencia de
perdón la biología la creencia bruce
lipton les decía un tema muy importante
dice que el 5% del día estamos actuando
de manera consciente el 95% del día
estamos trabajando con la parte
inconsciente de nuestro cerebro
imagínense la cantidad de cosas que
están sucediendo sin que siquiera pasen
por un juicio de valor de parte de mi
persona
y en ese sentido me puse a reflexionar
de tantas cosas que el día de hoy quiero
traer
más allá de tus límites es el concepto
que te dé extra el día de hoy nos
comparte
y al establecerlo seguramente la entidad
de los speakers que el día de hoy van a
estar
estarán compartiendo que los límites van
en nuestro sistema de creencias
luego denominar el sistema de creencias
limitantes y a partir de ahí me gustaría
desarrollar el concepto
la épica competencia como ya lo comenté
es método
constancia introspección y hábito tiene
que ver muchísimo con el concepto del yo
competente que me gustaría compartir con
todos ustedes esté yo competente lo
tengo esa información prácticamente
desde que yo creo estaba
en la carrera de administración
seguramente
y no es otra cosa más que la suma de
conocimientos habilidades y destrezas y
actitudes cuando tú sumas esas tres
cosas empiezas a desarrollar un dios
competente lo han utilizado mucho en la
parte de las competencias laborales de
la competencia académica pero esteban
muy vinculado a hacer un análisis de una
evaluación de cada uno de estos puntos
hablar de conocimientos es hablar de
todo lo que tiene que ver con
información datos en fin todo lo que es
la parte informativa de conocimiento la
parte de habilidades en la parte
psicomotora es yo puedo hacer algo pero
la parte de actitudes va con las
emociones los sentimientos los estados
de ánimo desarrollar esa parte implica
que cuando yo tengo conocimiento yo
tengo el yo sé
cuando tengo habilidades y destrezas es
el yo puedo pero cuando tengo actitudes
es el yo quiero y en ese sentido es yo
sé que puedo hacer las cosas yo puedo
hacer las cosas y yo quiero hacer las
cosas y eso estimados socios de
aprendizaje perdón que les denomina así
porque hay que recordar que así como
estamos lanzando perlas de sabiduría así
estamos nosotros también apoyando gran
información al momento de estar
exponiendo socios de aprendizaje lo que
estoy compartiendo al final de cuentas
es el método sobre el cual parto
es el yo competente cada vez que la
demanda que yo tengo para poder aplicar
mi propósito en la vida yo tengo que
desarrollar una competencia inclusiva
está para descansar tengo que
desarrollar la competencia tengo que
generar conocimientos en generar
habilidades y tengo que quedar actitud
de hacerlo en ese sentido cuando ya
tengo el método la epi competencia
empieza a generar su magia porque porque
implica ese ese yo competente tenga que
estar vinculado a la constancia y la
disciplina estricta disciplina y es ahí
cuando empieza empieza la magia ahora sí
del proceso de la epi competencia
al hablar de este proceso de que ya
tengo método constantemente lo estoy
aplicando que es la segunda palabra que
utilice para definir mi competencia
viene este término que dice la sabiduría
es el resultado del análisis de tus
experiencias
hace aproximadamente 40 días estaba en
una conferencia con john maxwell
principales mentores en mi desarrollo
del pensamiento
estaba hablando john maxwell imagínense
la emoción que tenía de estar por
primera vez fred físicamente de pronto
entre dentro de su charla menciona este
concepto la sabiduría es el resultado
del análisis de tus experiencias
volteado y decía la
se estaba guillermo un muy buen amigo a
un lado y si te pasa
y si el resumen
no pues si comparecía así es
no no no no es que la sabiduría se
inicie si ya lo entendí amigos cuando
están en este tipo de procesos pónganse
alertas porque las perlas de sabiduría
es decir las ideas que van al aire de
pronto pueden cambiarte tu vida y
créanme que eso les estoy compartiendo
tiene mucho sentido con este tipo de
frases y una vez que las cartas las
acuñas las haces propias las metes
dentro tu sistema de creencias y
desarrollas una salida
con muchísimas veces no había sabido
cómo establecer esa conexión con algo
más tangible entonces lo agregué a mi
concepto de competencia ya tengo el
metro ya tengo la constancia de estar
repitiendo el método y ahora llego a la
reflexión al análisis y ahí va la
tercera palabra que la parte de la
introspección
una vez que introspección sobre todos
esos conocimientos habilidades y
destrezas actitudes sobre algo que va a
vincular mi propósito de vida es cuando
continúa la magia porque independiente
que como lleves el proceso de
introspección ya está relajándose con
yoga llevando a cabo procesos de
coaching por ejemplo la clave es que
esas experiencias que vayas adquiriendo
con la competencia con elio competente
las pongas en una reflexión de cambio de
mirada
para esa inspección llega el cambio de
mirada permite empezar a retar a tus
creencias limitantes
una vez que retrasa la creencia
limitante ahí es cuando te das cuenta
que puedes solucionarlo de distintas
maneras demuestra tus experiencias de
vida muy rápidas la primera es 18 años
aproximadamente tenía el servidor
y tenía un pánico hablar en público
tiene un pánico agarrar un micrófono a
los 10 y 8 años pronto un día llega a
guadalupe extraordinario amigo mentor de
vida en un grupo juvenil que teníamos
colocó una bocina conectó un micrófono y
dijo jóvenes el día de hoy vamos a
hablar por micrófono inmediatamente me
dice para atrás trate de esconderme y me
coloque atrás de una de las compañeras
dije yo no hablo
ni de chiste
y en un momento que ya no tenían otra
opción ya estaba totalmente acorralado
me parece atrás había un poco
a 20 mis primeros conceptos y de pronto
dije no es tan malo y empecé a
desarrollar el método conocimientos me
empecé a meter cursos de oratoria me
empecé a meter a cursos para que me
enseñaran opciones para hablar en
público
empecé a desarrollar habilidades ya todo
evento y quería poner este hablar en
público
la actitud estaba floreciendo pero qué
era lo que pasaba que mi creencia
limitante me impedía lanzarme desde el
inicio segundo ejemplo que eso les va a
dar mucho sentido a las personas que
están vinculadas en el tema empresarial
y tiene que ver con los sistemas de
gestión de calidad
tendría 33 64 actos estaba en la ciudad
de méxico trabajando una institución muy
grande de protegida francisco un
extraordinario amigo además era mi jefe
me dice luis armando tenemos la
obligación de implantar un sistema de
gestión de calidad y tú eres la persona
indicada por todos los dioses tú vas a
lanzarte como líder del proyecto
inmediatamente creencias limitantes y yo
no se des
y si tenía algo de referencias pero yo
no sé es que yo no puedo no tengo las
habilidades para ello es que no tengo la
actitud simple y sencillamente no quiero
hacerlo
luís armando es el elegido
dos meses después dando dando pasos por
ahí de que no quería hacerlo voy a las
primeras charlas en nuestra terna de
socios terminé desarrollando e innovando
un nuevo sistema para implantar un
sistema de gestión de calidad en menos
de 10 meses toda la institución estuvo
certificada en el programa de hizo y a
la fecha tengo tres y tres experiencias
de certificación donde he sido el
responsable quiero lo que pasaba que las
creencias limitantes no me permiten ir
más allá de mis límites
entonces con esta parte de introspección
que les estoy compartiendo que dice john
maxwell
el tema de tener la reflexión es
importante dentro de la competencia
ahí surge un concepto que en lo personal
me dio muchísimo sentido y es
lo que dice henry ford henry ford dice
la gente exitosa
siempre y sencillamente el secreto está
en que sepa para que estuvo en esta vida
y simplemente lo haga
el secreto de una vida exitosa implica
saber a qué estamos determinados a hacer
y simplemente hacerlo y lo vinculó con
lo que dice precisamente john maxwell
john marvel dice primero descubre tu
propósito una vida número dos crece
hasta alcanzar su máximo potencial y
número tres siembra semillas que ayuden
a los demás
cuando entiendo eso descarte esto para
este concepto del día de hoy que quiero
compartir en la segunda que es crecer
para alcanzar su máximo potencial
para alcanzar su máximo potencial en tu
propósito de vida sentido lo que quiero
analizar frente a ustedes con estas dos
variables potenciar por un lado y tiempo
por el otro en ese sentido
lo que nos lleva es cambiar de una
posición a una posición b sin embargo
cuando lo hacemos con nuestras creencias
limitantes cuando lo hacemos a través de
nuestro nuestro status quo nuestra zona
de confort vamos a estar una posición
plana hay un cambio en el tiempo si lo
más probable amigos es de que lo único
que consigamos hacer diferente la
fusionada ive sea un montón de canas un
montón de arrugas y un montón de veces
pero aquí la clave son dos conceptos es
crecer a tu máximo entonces tendría que
cambiar ese hay sb posición en diagonal
ascendente que te lleve a un real
crecimiento
es más de debería estar totalmente fuera
de la pantalla porque es un proceso de
vida tu potencial implica
viajar continuamente en un proceso de
crecimiento desarrollo y visión visión
hacia dónde quieres ir a ese propósito
de vida
mucho una meta no es un evento no es un
producto es un viaje continuo y
permanente y en ese sentido la epi
compete a que hay que hacer para crecer
y por eso quiero empezar a cerrar con el
concepto epp y competente que vuelvo a
darles que es establecer el método ser
constante con ese método en todas las
demandas que tiene un propósito de vida
número 3
hacer introspección con la confrontación
que vas aprendiendo con el método y
número 4 genera el hábito entonces esto
es una forma de ejemplificar la parte de
la epi competencia tenemos un círculo
que está marcando de la al b de forma
ascendente y en el círculo tenemos las
iniciales de ser conocimientos h de
habilidades y de actitudes es el
competente pero está en un color dorado
es decir ya pasó por constancia ya paseó
por introspección y ahora no tengo una
posición donde estoy listo para que me
ayude a crecer una vez que lo empujó a
crecer automáticamente tener un hábito
que un hábito es
repetidamente y de manera consciente
elaboro acciones y pensamientos
repetir conscientemente acciones y
pensamientos porque lo que pasa cuando
tú no lo anclas es de que con el tiempo
se retorna nuevamente a la posición
lo que propongo en este concepto de mi
competencia es
crecer y anclar lo para que no pueda
tener reversa y volver a crecer y volver
anclas pero con un nuevo hábito y así en
cada una de las demandas que tenga un
sito de vida implica tener qué
aprender a hablar en público lo voy a
hacer porque mi idea es generarle valor
a las personas pero general o con su
mente y crece con ello hasta alcanzar su
máximo potencial ese concepto de la
competencia que espero que cada uno de
ustedes puede haber adquirido en esta
charla y si no han además charlas de los
compañeros esas pequeñas ideas que
puedan agarrar las para que les ayuden a
crecer en su vida como para mí fuego de
sabiduría
concierto de bruce de dónde desafiar las
creencias limitantes
así se los propongo ustedes que alguna
de las ideas que les haya compartido el
día de hoy les sirva para alcanzar su
máximo potencial y para cerrar estimados
amigos socios de aprendizaje cada uno
los que están aquí la verdad es mi socio
de aprendizaje
se dice que cuando pasamos por un
proceso vivencial de enseñanza
hay que dar que si no hay cambio de
comportamiento no hubo aprendizaje
si pudiéramos levantar la mano quien
aprendió algo nuevo de esa charla
y yo les diría no es cierto no
aprendieron absolutamente nada el día de
hoy porque porque el aprendizaje se
demostrara el día de mañana que se
levanten con la firme convicción de
establecer un método de establecer
constancia en el método de establecer un
proceso de introspección y reflexión de
esas experiencias y por último de
generar hábitos de repetir
constantemente que eso es lo que quieren
de la vida y ahí comentan mi buen amigo
robert by robert para que su facilitador
profesionales aprende pero aprende
demostrándolo con un cambio del
comportamiento
estimados amigos nuestro país necesita
líderes necesita gente que salga de la
zona de confort y gente que crezca hasta
su máximo potencial muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]